de la population mondiale
vivait dans les villes.
Et je peux vous parier
que beaucoup de ces gens ont pensé
à faire les choses différemment.
« Si seulement j'avais les outils
pour changer les choses dans ma ville,
que ferais-je ? »
« Quelle serait la ville de mes rêves ? »
Et ces outils,
nous leur avons donné.
Il y a 2 ans, mon équipe et moi
avons lancé un jeu,
« Cities: Skylines ».
C'est un jeu pour construire des villes.
J'ai toujours été intéressée par les villes en tant que systèmes.
C'est une chose que je trouve vraiment intéressante.
Mais je n'ai pas compris
que je ne suis pas la seule à l'être.
Les gens aiment les villes.
Ils sont intéressés. Ils ont des idées.
Le jeu fut un succès instantané.
Depuis, plus de 3 millions et demi de personnes y ont joué.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement de jouer.
Nous avons aussi des systèmes de partage vraiment géniaux.
Donc, on joue, on crée des villes
et puis on partage ces créations,
pour montrer ce que l'on a fait.
Je vais vous montrer
certaines de ces villes
créées par les joueurs.
Il s'agit d'expression personnelle,
de créativité,
pas seulement de surmonter les défis de la simulation.
Il s'agit de montrer à quoi ressemblent vos villes.
J'ai deux vidéos.
Elles viennent de YouTube.
Elles font partie des villes les plus intéressantes que j'ai vu.
Elles sont toutes différentes,
et j'espère que vous les aimerez toutes.
Celle-ci s'appelle « Les Pays-Bas ».
Crééé par Silvarret.
Quand on commence le jeu,
on a un terrain vide.
Ce terrain peut être basé sur le monde réel,
il peut être fabriqué à la main dans l'éditeur de carte,
ou on peut, bien sûr, télécharger une ville créée par un autre
et jouer dessus.
Ce que Silvarret a fait ici,
ce qu'il a voulu fabriquer,
n'était pas une ville réelle.
C'est une ville imaginaire,
même si elle paraît réelle.
Il a voulu faire une ville imaginaire qui pourrait être aux Pays-Bas.
Il s'est donc renseigné
sur les caractéristiques des villes aux Pays-Bas
et en a combiné plusieurs.
Voici ce qu'il a créé.
C'est une ville,
elle n'est pas réelle
mais elle pourrait l'être.
Elle ressemble parfaitement aux Pays-Bas.
Les lieux sont vraiment très peuplés.
Il y a donc besoin d'autoroutes, de trains,
tout ce qui lie ces petits centres-villes ensemble.
Beaucoup de monde, beaucoup de mouvements,
le transport est donc la solution.
Allons encore plus du côté imaginaire.
Entrons dans le futur.
Celui-ci est un de mes préférés.
Ces modèles de villes sont ceux que j'aime le plus.
Voici une ville à plusieurs niveaux créée par Conflictnerd,
et l'idée de base est que les routes sont en cercles concentriques.
Donc, la ville est un grand cercle
avec de plus petits cercles dedans.
Le but est de mettre tous les services au centre
et les habitants se trouvent dans le cercle extérieur,
car il y a moins de trafic, moins de bruit et de pollution.
C'est l'endroit idéal où s'installer.
Mais les services sont quand même à proximité.
Ils sont au centre.
Et ça, c'est l'âme du jeu.
Le joueur doit comprendre
quelles sont les espérances, quels sont les besoins,
des petites personnes qui vivent dans les villes.
Il faut savoir où mettre les choses.
Par exemple, il ne suffit pas d'avoir un hôpital.
Il doit être accessible.
Les citoyens ont besoin d'accéder à l'hôpital.
Et c'est une façon de faire.
C'est une chose que l'on pourrait voir un jour.
À présent, encore plus futuriste.
Astergea par Yuttho.
Yuttho fait des vidéos sur YouTube et joue à ce jeu.
En fait, il a fait une série de 12 points
sur la création de cette ville.
Il joue,
il enregistre
et il explique en même temps ce qu'il fait et pourquoi.
Dans cette série,
il a interrogé un vrai urbaniste
nommé Jeff Speck.
Speck est un expert dans le concept de marchabilité.
L'idée de base est que si l'on veut que nos citoyens marchent,
ce qui est une bonne chose,
il faut considérer la marche comme un moyen de transport judicieux.
Ça devrait être un bon moyen pour se déplacer.
Donc, Yuttho a expliqué ce concept,
tout comme Speck,
puis il l'a appliqué à la ville qu'il construisait.
Donc, ce que nous voyons est la vision du futur selon Yuttho :
beaucoup de transports, de rues piétonnes, de centres commerciaux,
reliant les grandes tours.
Peut-être que le futur ressemblera à ça.
Le système du jeu est parfait pour ça.
On voit de réels usages dans ce jeu.
On sait que certains urbanistes l'utilisent comme un outil de dessin,
donc même si la simulation n'est pas complétement réaliste,
elle l'est suffisamment pour que si une chose fonctionne dans le jeu,
il est fort probable qu'elle fonctionnera aussi dans le monde réel.
En fait, on peut essayer des choses
et voir si ce carrefour convient à ce type de situation.
Si l'on construit une nouvelle route, va-t-elle aider ?
Et c'est ce que l'on peut faire avec ce jeu.
Il y avait un concours intéressant organisé
par la ville finnoise de Hämeenlinna.
Ils avaient en tête cette nouvelle zone
qu'ils voulaient développer dans la ville.
Ils ont créé une carte de la ville existante,
ils ont laissé vide la zone qu'ils voudraient développer
et ils ont partagé cette carte.
N'importe qui pouvait télécharger la carte,
jouer, construire la zone
et proposer sa création au conseil municipal.
Ils n'ont encore rien construit
mais il est possible qu'ils utilisent un de ces plans
faits avec le jeu
pour construire la vraie ville.
Et ces vidéos que je vous ai montrées,
ce sont les personnes qui trouvent de nouvelles solutions.
On sait que les villes se développent.
Elles grandissent au fur et à mesure,
et le pourcentage de la population qui habite en ville va augmenter.
Alors nous avons besoin de solutions
et ces personnes, tout en jouant,
essaient différents types de solutions.
Elles peuvent proposer des choses très importantes.
Ce que nous voyons, ce sont des villes de rêve qui existeront peut-être un jour.
Alors, il est possible
que ce ne soit pas juste un jeu.
Il peut être un moyen
de décider de notre propre sort.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)